the first time I heard Kanye West on
Jesus walks in 2004 there was something
about the way that he spoke about Jesus
and the way that he approached things in
a manner which he was using a kind of
gangster language about about hustlers
and gangsters and all of this but he was
strangely flipping it in a manner to
bring it almost into a strange gospel
song the first time I heard that I
started to pay attention to Kanye West
and I have been paying attention to him
from afar from a certain distance since
then and so I was not completely
surprised to see what is happening with
him recently though I am can I say this
I'm happy to see my attention pay off
and so I'm going to try to explain to
you what's going on to the extent that I
can understand in terms of Kanye's new
album and in terms of this strange
social moment that we're in how it all
fits together and how when the world is
upside down we need to pay attention to
the fools and now is the time to pay
attention to someone like Kanye
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so I just got back from Chicago I was in
Chicago for the weekend giving a talk at
st. John Cantus Church I'll be putting
those talks up as soon as they're ready
and there was something of a strange
coming together of elements that I was
going to Chicago during that time that
on Sunday the traditional church was
celebrating a feast called Christ the
King and that Kanye West I just put up
his album called Jesus's King all of
this and that Kanye is from Chicago and
talked about Chicago all the time all of
these elements were kind of coming
together and so in my talk I I discussed
Kanye and the relationship to sacred art
you'll have to watch that talk to get
the full relationship to sacred art but
I thought it would be important to go
into what is going on because it's
happening now this is the moment that
that this album came out and that Kanye
is making waves in the culture so why do
I say that we need to watch the fools
I've made several videos about this that
we're living in a world that is upside
down where the exception has become the
rule where the margins have become king
we the aesthetics of the carnival are
all around us the spinning this turning
the entertainment mode everything about
our world is is carnivalesque and
usually it is the fool which brings us
to that moment is the fool the clown all
of these types of characters that bring
us into this upside-down world of
spinning and entertainment and of excess
but my contention for the past few years
it has been if the fool is the one who
turns things upside down then the fool
is also the one who turns things
right-side up and that is why for the
past ten years for the past decade I
have been watching for these fools to
appear on the horizon and we saw some of
them in the last few years people like
Miley innopolis people like Gavin
McGinnis who had all the imagery of the
fool people who were somewhat in who had
come into a kind of excessive culture
you know
was the founder of Vice and all of a
sudden he becomes a Christian and starts
to become more conservative
there are several characters like that
like I said Milo was also one of those
characters but Kanye was one that I've
been watching for a very long time when
I heard for the first time the song
jesus walks in 2004 I was really
surprised at the way that he was able to
use the aesthetic of gangsta rap with a
certain talk about violence and
gang-related violence and hustlers and
all this but then somehow flip it in a
manner which is to say that Christ is
always with the lowest is always walking
with the lowest and there was something
about the way he did that that made me
want to pay attention so I have been
watching him from afar for a very long
time
when I saw that he married this when I
saw that he what some point I saw that
he was like dating a stripper and then
he married Kim Kardashian and I was
reminded of stories in moments of
inversion where the prophets are asked
to marry a [ __ ] there's the story of
King David who is very much that holy
fool you know he's an entertainer King
David was an entertainer he was the
youngest of his peers he was the
smallest one he also he had a bang a
gang of thieves and ruffians with him he
pretended to be crazy he did all these
things he also married other people's
wives and so King David is a figure to
understand the holy fool is really a
figure to watch and I would say pay
attention because my brother Mets here
is currently it seems writing a book
about King David to help us understand
this moment in our culture but so I we
bit material and and I have worked also
with me has been watching Kanye my
brother Matt's here to understand is he
possibly this fool that's going to flip
that's going to go in a way to the
bottom and is going to become this
extremely inverted character but then
he's going to flip back up and so there
was a point where I was even I couldn't
pay attention to Connie too much because
his last albums were so were so crass
and so vulgar and so blasphemous
you know blaspheming calling himself God
and saying that he's Jesus basically and
so
really went to the end he went right to
the edge where he married a woman that
is exactly the image of this this [ __ ]
who became famous for making a sex tape
and who was you know famous for being
famous represents all this excess all of
this sensuousness and so then when last
year when Connie kind of went crazy and
then went into the asylum my focus
started to pay attention to him even
more the fact that he saw supporting
Trump as a form of ultimate rebellion
all of that just everything about that
seemed that it was something to pay
attention to and so finally these Sunday
services really does mark a transition
and I think it's a to transition it's
not the only transition we've seen in
the past few years but it's one which I
think is important because it does
represent that flip from someone who
went all the way to the bottom of pop
culture and now is flipping there is a
one of the things I've been telling you
guys about is about the problem of
entertainment and the problem of
reducing culture to entertainment and
what that does to people
ancient culture what we call culture
ancient culture was participative
stories were participative they were
your stories you people you know people
would come and tell stories around fires
they would have a poetic meter in which
to tell ballads and stories and romances
of the famous characters in your story
the same for the stories in the gospel
it was the same for music and dancing
they had folk dancing and music and
music and dancing were actually
participative there are some little
remainders of that and things like
square dancing where the the dancing is
not just you dancing you know just to
show off or to to be in your own little
world or to seduce somebody but rather
to participate in bringing people
together and manifesting the unity that
exists among people and so dancing can
play that role it doesn't play that role
so much anymore but what I'm what I
wanted to get people to understand is
that when we see things like cosplay and
we
see things like fanfiction and you know
kind of Star Wars crazy Star Wars fans
who dress up as characters who are
trying to live in those worlds what
we're seeing is that hunger for
participation we see the same with Harry
Potter and of course with Marvel Comics
all of this that people have this desire
to participate in a story but you can't
you can't participate fully in that
story it isn't your story and someone
pointed out to me recently that not only
is it not your story but that story is
actually owned by people it is a
trademark these stories are trademarked
which are owned by people and so your
desire to participate in that story is
becomes very shady because it is what is
it end up being buying merch buying the
products consuming the the products now
ancient stories like religious stories
were that were those that you ended up
plunging into and being part of and so
what we're seeing is in Kanye's new
album what we're seeing is him realizing
that music without purpose ends up being
and leads you to nothing and there's a
there's a quote in one of the songs I'm
probably gonna I'm gonna paraphrase it
because I don't have it in front of me
where he says let the demons know this
is a mission not a show and I think that
that's the flip I think that that's the
flip that's happening which is that
people are coming to the end of
entertainment culture as entertainment
culture is becoming overwhelming I mean
we have more movies more TV shows more
video games
we're just drowning in entertainment but
that drowning and entertainment also
marks a tipping point where all of a
sudden we are saturated every we know
people are people are drunk on
entertainment and so as you reach the
end of that as you reach the bottom the
only way to go is to move towards
purpose and to move towards arts culture
that brings together that has the
purpose of making you participate in the
story so when you look at Kanye's Sunday
services you can see that that's what's
happening instead of having a performer
and an audience he's setting things up
in a circle where all the singers are in
a circle together and they're looking at
each other and they're singing in a
manner which is it is communicative
which is trying to create unity amongst
the people that are doing it and so
although it's still a show and it's very
awkward and a lot of the things that
Kanye says his album are extremely
awkward you know it's a mix of praising
but then there's always these weird
moments of boasting and these weird
moments there's a place in one of the
songs where he he complains about the
IRS and and he said that's why he
charges so much for his products because
if he didn't and his family would star
it's like okay kinda we don't we don't
feel sorry for you but I think it's
important to see it from as a broader
phenomena even though I don't think that
you could see Kanye as some kind of a
leader
some kind of someone that you need to
pay attention to in terms of the the
quality of his message you could say you
mostly have to see what's going on and
see what he's doing and and what he's
manifesting as a marker in a social
pattern as we see the social pattern
manifest itself as we see this moving
towards this culture moving completely
towards bread and circus and then
realizing that man cannot live by bread
and circus alone that's the shift that
we're seeing and we shouldn't be
surprised that it's the fool who brings
about that flip and some of the the
things that have been happening have
been crazy I mean to watch Kim
Kardashian baptized Hurst get baptized
herself and baptize her children in the
Armenian Orthodox faith you know and to
watch Kanye West who has had devolved
into this extremely crass person all of
a sudden have this desire to create
worship music that is a social marker
because when things start to fall when
for a change to happen it has to happen
at the bar
and that is very difficult for people to
understand the spark comes from the top
of the hierarchy but the change happens
at the bottom and so when you watch when
you watch for example the rise of
Christianity in Rome you can understand
that the the first to convert to
Christianity when there is a an actual
revolution when there is a change in the
structure of things when there's a a
renewal for good or for bad that is when
there's something changes paradigms it
the spark starts at the top but the
shift happens at the bottom and that's
why Christians were the poorest of the
poor were slaves where women were all
the lower parts of society and they're
the ones who brought about that shift
and then all of that connected together
in terms of heaven and earth you can see
it you can see it for example like the
fact that very strong moments in culture
like Dante who wrote his poem in a
secular in a common Italian language
rather than writing it in Latin because
he was he was at that point of
transition he was he is one of the
characters that marks the transition
from the Middle Ages into this new age
and there are many examples of that and
so that's also one of the reasons why
you always have to watch the when things
are getting shady when things are
getting crazy you have to look down you
have to look at the bottom and see what
spark in the darkness is going to start
to shine and I think that that's one of
the things we're seeing now and we're
seeing this flip happen it's something
that I've been looking forward to for a
long time that I've hinted at that I've
told you about and so I think we need to
continue to pay attention and I would
say be careful in the sense that Kanye
West is a trickster Kanye West is a fool
character and you know he he can bring
about he can manifest this shift but he
is a shifty character don't put your
trust on him because he can go either
way at any point he can he can
completely change and go in another
direction and
when that wouldn't be surprising either
but rather we do need to see that the
desire for participation is real in our
culture and worship celebration
realizing that that is actually what
culture is pointing to the desire to
celebrate things now you can celebrate
dark things you can celebrate one of the
things that for example since the advent
of rock-and-roll has basically been a
celebration of sexuality but you
sometimes darker things and that as well
but that is really what music ends up
being now the question is what are you
celebrating and once you understand that
you can have something like music which
is a celebration but then becomes a
participatory thing and becomes a
participatory thing which is celebrating
the highest that's when you realize that
the ultimate purpose of music and of
culture is worship it just depends what
you're worshipping but if you can align
that worship towards the highest thing
then you are you have the possibility of
creating a new stability for the mass a
new new ground to stand on you would say
and so I think keep paying attention to
what's going on I'm telling you guys for
sure with this happening this whole
Kanye West thing 2020 put on your seat
belt guys cuz 2020 is going to be a
crazy year and who knows what direction
it's going to go but pay attention
because things are about to speed up if
you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribed
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends if you can get involved in
the discussion we have a Facebook group
in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com